I don't think any of us have seen the
indictment yet so I wait till they
unseal the indictment to see how sillier
stupid I think it is but hey if you
broke the law take a shot of the book
thrown at him I have an ex-president I
don't believe are above the law so I
absolutely agree I'd like to see more
presidents get arrested in church oh I
may make me nervous guys that's the
first time in history a president's ever
been indicted you know I I agree I don't
care if if they break the law then they
should be charged my issue I suppose is
it seems overtly political I mean how
can we say that without seeing the
indictment that's a fair point but you
just said that but it seems overtly
political we don't know for sure but it
seems that way especially considering
the dude campaigned on investigating
Trump they spent years and this was the
best they could come up with that Cohen
paid Stormy Daniels to not write a book
or give an interview or whatever about
banging Trump and that Trump tried
claiming it was legal fees despite the
fact that a letter was put out 2018
where Cohen where Cohen's lawyer said
Cohen paid for it out of pocket was
never reimbursed